hey I'm Tony Hawk's Pro Skater and this
is the wire and autocomplete interview
and go ok let's complete the
autocomplete first one is can Tony Hawk
I'm guessing can Tony Hawk do a 900
still skate yes I can still skate I
still skate often actually I would say
three or four times a week especially
since Co vid and no travel
I've just been either home or at my ramp
or actually in backyard pools and just
located my fingers last weekend so yeah
I'm still skating cam Tony Hawk's Street
skate the short answer is kinda I went
through a big street phase in the early
90s because there were hardly any vert
ramps around skating was all about
Street handrails and ledges and things
like that and I did as best as I could
until I rolled both my ankles twice so
severely that it was sort of risking my
sense of being able to skate at all
again and so I just sort of focused in
on transition and ramp skating been
doing it ever since
so yes I have some dormant Street skills
I can do the handrails I can do a few
kickflip variations but not in the
traditional sense that you see
especially on TV or like X Games can
Tony Hawk kickflip yes I can I was about
13 years old when kick plus were
actually invented by rodney Mullen and I
learned them shortly thereafter I still
do them they're not beautiful I don't
catch them very high but yes I can kick
a loop and so I feel justified when I go
and ask kids do a kickflip because I
walk the walk
alright can Tony Hawk still do a 900 I
do one a couple years ago I think that
if I was really motivated and I had the
right incentive I don't mean like
financial I just mean in terms of like
emotional incentive to do it I could
probably throw him down if you're gonna
go try a 900 the incentives to go do it
and make it and so I know going into it
if I'm gonna go try 900 I'm definitely
gonna take a few knocks along the way
and I have to be fully prepared for that
it takes so much out of you just to
attempt it there's no reason to just
test it out
Kent Tony Hawk's Singh I'm gonna leave
that for you to judge because I did the
math singer I was voted first out in my
group I don't know if that means I can
or can't sing it's probably not a good
sign but I think I can I come from a
line of musicians in my family so my dad
he knew how to play a lot of different
sermons my sister was actually a backup
singer for Michael Bolton and for the
Righteous Brothers John Denver and the
Pet Shop Boys and so I feel like I had
enough I don't know hereditary skill to
do it can't Tony Hawk's sir yes I can
serve I've been surfing almost as long
as I'm in skating I don't put the effort
into trying to go out when it's good
because my schedule is crazy and so if I
were to actually be chasing swells I
would have to compromise a lot more in
my life I that is one excuse but I went
to Kelly Slater surf ranch couple weeks
ago got pitted so yeah I can surf Ken
Tony Hawk's snowboard yes been
snowboarding since they first made
snowboards first time I went
snowboarding was in 1982 so I've
definitely been snowboarding longer than
you
where was Tony Hawk born and raised San
Diego California my dad was in the Navy
and he was stationed in San Diego and he
retired
lucky me we just ended up here and
stayed let's see where did Tony Hawk go
to high school well it's funny I say I
stayed in San Diego mom my parents
actually did move around San Diego while
I was in school so I went to my freshman
year at San Dieguito high school now
known as San Dieguito Academy moved to
Torrey Pines High School in my sophomore
year and graduated there San Dieguito
was rough back then honestly and that's
why I asked him move schools I was a
skater I got picked on a lot which we
now know is bullying I would literally
get hassled in the hallways just because
they knew I skated I was already really
small and
kind of nerdy and then the fact that I
skated was just like not to you that
dude sucks it got a little bit better
Torrey Pines but I can't say it was the
most pleasant experience all right where
does Tony Hawk live now Encinitas North
San Diego it's a metropolitan area but
it's not crazy like Los Angeles where
it's just gridlocked traffic all the
time I just love that there's a very
strong surf skate culture here and there
always has been and really the reason I
loved it so much as the kid is because
one of the last skate parks in the US
was right here and that was where I
developed most of my skills and really
honed my style
all right where has Tony Hawk been
really is that really an auto-fill that
comes up where has Tony Hawk been maybe
they mean just in terms of in the public
eye where I've been been right here
doing my thing
skating raising a family you know maybe
I'm not on Punk'd or maybe you haven't
seen me on talk shows recently but I've
stayed the course just doing my thing I
think that maybe people will start to
learn a lot more about me in this coming
year because thanks to my master class
and thanks to the thps remaster but um
where have I been just raising kids and
skating that's where I've been
is Tony Hawk I can already sense that
one of these says is Tony Hawk alive the
rumors of my death are greatly
exaggerated by the way he's talking a
hawk a nice guy what a strange question
ask Google it's just a matter of opinion
it does the Google dude I don't know do
I have any sort of Yelp reviews on
myself how would anyone know that I'd
like to think I'm a nice guy I have a
great relationship with my kids I love
interacting with fans and I get to
skateboard for a living and that I think
in itself is what makes me friendly cuz
I get to I live my dream is Tony Hawk a
good skater again a matter of opinion
I would say if I had to judge myself I'm
very good for my age all right is Tony
Hawk a vegetarian I am NOT a vegetarian
I do lean towards plant-based foods my
friend said it best was and he said um
hey Tony I know you kind of lean towards
vegetarianism but I bet you'd have a
steak and he's right I would I love
barbecue - all right is Tony Hawk a
Boomer I am NOT a Boomer
I am Gen X my older siblings are boomers
and you know it's funny is somehow this
is an insult it only means that you were
part of the baby boomer generation and
that was the generation of families that
came back from the war and then everyone
was having babies that is what the baby
boomer generation is people there's your
lesson in generations I was born in 1968
not boomer
it's Tony Hawk British no but there is a
British comedian named Tony Hawk's I
think he truly despises my existence
because people get him confused they get
his name confused they send him fan mail
on my behalf they actually invited me on
a morning show in London a long time ago
and surprised me with him as a guest as
well and then he got to basically chew
me out his Tony Hawk going to the
Olympics I was planning to go to the
Olympics to be a commentator of sorts
but not to be a skater representing the
United States of America there are much
more qualified skaters and trust me you
don't want me being there just because
you know my name I'm 52 and I'm a vert
skater
that's a park discipline and we have
such talent in the US and they deserve
to be there so I'd much rather be behind
the mic explaining to all you what
exactly they're doing
it's Tony Hawk you'll be feted yes I am
good be fitted right foot forward and
I'm not very good at skating switch so
I'm not gonna say I'm ambidextrous and
yep I may be foot it is Tony Hawk
sponsored by bands yes I am and here is
proof Dalton I'm wearing right now my
first ski she was vans in 1979 that I
insisted my dad buy for me because I saw
an ad for them and the skateboarder
magazine and I was like skateboard shoes
I ride skateboards
I want those I've been through various
sponsors since then and came back to
vans and I'm thankful does Tony Hawk hmm
wear a helmet for the most part I wear a
helmet
especially when I'm skating bigger ramps
and that's kind of my thing
beer amps if I'm out cruising Street
skating skating smaller stuffs generally
I don't and I'm sure that some people
would complain about that but it's more
about my experience level I encourage
people are learning to skate to wear a
helmet because you never know what's
gonna happen and a lot of times you can
fall back very quickly if I'm on a big
ramp and we're in a helmet and it saved
my life
plenty of times if you're gonna skate
vert you probably know where element
does Tony Hawk still compete not in the
traditional sense every once in a while
I will jump into an event if there's
sort of a legends division or maybe
there's like a best trick thing and I
feel like I might have something that I
can contribute I'm actually I'm in a
really good place because I get to pick
and choose which events I want to go to
because I'm not really trying to earn
points I'm not trying to keep my status
up like that does Tony Hawk have tattoos
I do have tattoos I have this one right
here which is a dr. Wu tattoo of a
skateboard and some planets and then if
you can see closely it has initials of
my wife and all of our children sort of
sprinkled out throughout here and then I
have a kind of a falcon head tattoo on
my ankle that is not the finest work
I'll show you you see that not the most
intricate work but the funny thing is is
that I got it because I thought it'd be
cool I used to wear low socks all the
time and so you know any video or
pictures you'll see this hawk and then I
started getting burns on the sides of my
ankles from the socks and so I ended up
just wearing long socks after that and
now you never see it does Tony Hawk have
fake teeth yes many these four right
here I've knocked him out a few times
each I chipped them really badly and I
chipped him again and then there was
just sort of a little piece hanging on
one side and then I end up getting posts
right there does Tony Hawk longboard um
no not really
I prefer skateboards that I can maneuver
quickly and that I can do tricks on if
you longer it it's cool I think of a
more of a mode of transportation and I
have seen some people that do tricks on
them but you know
whatever gets you moving and if you're
on a skateboard as cool with me just
went out my brother I do I have an older
brother Steve Hawk and he is the one who
gave me my first skateboard he was a
surfer still as a surfer actually was
the editor of Surfer magazine for a
while that's first skateboard that he
gave me somehow I held onto it all
through the years and he and I donated
it to the Smithsonian a few years ago
which is very cool we got to fly to DC
together and hand it over
what is Tony Hawk pro skater that is our
video game franchise the first one was
released in 1999 Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
we kept releasing them almost every year
stopped for a while I wasn't working
with Activision and then just recently
we have decided to remaster Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater one and to literally 20 years
later we're releasing it for all the new
systems what Tony Hawk game is the best
there are all these subjective searches
how is that something that anyone can
decide it's all up to the eye of the
beholder
I would say the one that got the best
reviews was Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 2 I
think it still holds up as one of the
top 10 best reviewed games of all time
what skateboard does Tony Hawk right you
want me to go get my skateboard so this
is the skipper I ride it's a bird house
Falcon eight-and-a-half inches
independent trucks and bones 60
millimeter skatepark formula wheels this
thing has been used I think exactly
three days I will probably end up giving
it away in a couple weeks for like an
auction item or something like that they
usually want the whole skateboard which
would make a lot of skaters cringe
because once you get used to your trucks
that becomes what you rely on and that's
sort of your signature on how you turn
and once you break in your trucks you
you hold on to them forever I'm so used
to giving my boards away the complete
boards that I've just gotten used to
getting new trucks all the time and I'm
actually more used to new trucks than if
they're broken in what shoot is Tony
Hawk wear when I skate I wearing the
Vans old-school high tops just like I
did in 1984 but if I'm shelling I'm
wearing the slip ones like Spicoli thank
you
you for joining me for the wired
autocomplete interview it was very
thorough it was very cathartic and I
appreciate you including me doing your
searches sir John